ALL BALL DEMANDING A BUNCH OF
BAILOUT FROM WE THE PEOPLE.
FIRST TONIGHT, OUR TOP STORY, IT
IS TIME TO OPEN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT AWAY.
NOW, THIS IS THE COVER OF
"THE NEW YORK POST" TOMORROW.
IT READS "THE BIG APPLE IS
DYING, ITS STREETS ARE EMPTY,
TENS OF THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
PLUNGED INTO POVERTY.
OUR LEADERS HAVE NO PLAN, NO
ANSWERS, NEW YORKERS HAVE
ALREADY LEARNED TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE.
AS MRS. CAN ADJUST.
THE ELDERLY AND SICK CAN
CONTINUE TO BE ISOLATED, BUT IT
NEEDS TO END NOW."
HERE’S MY PRODUCTION, SO-CALLED
LEADERS, THEY WILL NOT LISTEN
UNTIL IT’S TOO LATE.
GRAB YOUR WALLETS IF YOU LIVE IN
NEW YORK.
YOU’RE ABOUT TO GET ROBBED.
THEY ARE GOING TO ROB YOU
BECAUSE I’LL NEVER BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR WAY OUT OF THIS MESS
THEY CREATED AND BY THE WAY, THE
WRITING IS ALREADY ON THE WALL.
LOOK AT THIS NEW STUDY.
JPMORGAN FIRST REPORTING CNBC,
INFECTION RATES HAVE DECLINED
AND NOT INCREASED IN STATES
WHERE LOCKDOWNS HAVE ENDED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF CONCLUSIVE
DATA, THESE LOCKDOWNS WERE
JUSTIFIED INITIALLY, BUT
MILLIONS OF LIVES WERE BEING
DESTROYED WITH LITTLE
CONSIDERATION THAT THE LOCKDOWNS
MIGHT NOT ONLY -- MIGHT NOT ONLY
CAUSE ECONOMIC DEVASTATION BUT
POTENTIALLY MORE DEATHS THAN
COVID-19 ITSELF.
NOW, IS ENDLESS,
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL, LOCKED ON
ORDERS LIKE THE GOVERNOR OF
MICHIGAN, THEY NEED TO END NOW.
RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS, WE KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS SAFELY.
AMERICANS ARE SCREAMING TO GET
THEIR FREEDOM AND THEIR COUNTRY
BACK AND THEY ARE EVEN WILLING
TO WEAR MASKS IN THE APPROPRIATE
SITUATIONS.
LORD I GOT IT RIGHT, TEXAS GOT
IT RIGHT, AND GUESS WHAT, NOW
IT’S TIME FOR ALL THE STATES TO
FOLLOW THEIR LEAD, AND BY THE
WAY, WE CAN LEARN FROM SOME
STATES THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE NEED TO
LEARN FROM THE ABJECT FAILURES,
MEANING NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, MICHIGAN, LOOK AT
YOUR SCREEN.
NEW CASES IN FLORIDA ARE NOW
DOWN 14% INTO THEIR REOPENING.
NEW CASES IN FLORIDA DOWN BY
12%.
LOOK AT THIS CHART, TENS OF
THOUSANDS MORE PEOPLE LOST THEIR
LIVES IN NEW YORK THAN IN
FLORIDA.
TENS OF THOUSANDS.
THOUSANDS MORE DIED IN
NEW JERSEY.
THOUSANDS MORE DIED IN MICHIGAN.
THOUSANDS MORE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
WHAT HAPPENED?
OKAY, THIS IS WHERE WE LEARN
FROM THE DUMB IDEAS AND THE DUMB
POLICIES THAT WERE MADE IN THE
MIDDLE OF CORONA, STARTED IN
NEW YORK, MARCH 25TH.
REMEMBER?
FLORIDA WENT OUT OF ITS WAY TO
GET COVID-19 PATIENTS OUT OF
NURSING HOMES, PROTECTING THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THE ELDERLY
POPULATION OF THAT STATE.
IN NEW YORK, MARCH 25TH, IN
NEW JERSEY, I BELIEVE THEY DID
IT MARCH 29TH, PENNSYLVANIA NOT
TO BE OUTDONE, THEY DID IT ON
APRIL THE SIXTH.
MICHIGAN JUST SCREWED EVERYTHING
UP FROM THE BEGINNING.
THEY ALL FORCED NURSING HOMES
AND LONG-TERM CARE FACILITIES TO
TAKE IN COVID-19 PATIENTS WHERE
THERE WERE NO COVID-19 PATIENTS.
THIS POLICY BECAME A DEATH
SENTENCE FOR MANY ELDERLY PEOPLE
AND ALL OF THE STATES AND
FACILITIES.
THIS WAS A LITERAL DEATH
SENTENCE.
DID THEY DO IT ON PURPOSE?
NO, I DON’T THINK THEY DID IT ON
PURPOSE.
DID THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY ARE
STUPID?
YEAH, THAT’S A BIG PART OF THE
REASON.
YOU HAVE EXECUTIVE ORDERS, ALL
THESE MANDATES IN THESE FOUR
STATES FOR EXAMPLE, NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, PENNSYLVANIA,
MICHIGAN.
THOSE DUMB POLICIES KILLED
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS IN THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, BY THE WAY, YOU
WILL GOVERNOR DeSANTIS A HUGE
APOLOGY BECAUSE YOU ACCUSED HIM
OF WANTING TO KILL GRANDMA.
BECAUSE THE OPEN FLORIDA
SPEECHES.
GRANDMA WASN’T GOING TO THE
BEACH IN HER BIKINI.
GRANDMA WAS SHELTERING IN PLACE,
HE SENT HIS NATIONAL GUARD IN
EVERY STATE AGENCY TO EVERY
ELDERLY CARE FACILITY AND
NURSING HOME IN THE VILLAGES SO
THEY WERE PREPARING THE WHOLE
TIME.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY WEREN’T WRONG.
OTHERS WERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FLORIDA HAS THE ABSOLUTE BEST
DATA, SO ANY INSINUATION
OTHERWISE IS JUST TYPICAL
PARTISAN NARRATIVE TRYING TO BE
SPUN AND PART OF THE REASON IS
THAT BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN YOUR PROFESSION WHO
WAX POETICALLY FOR WEEKS AND
WEEKS ABOUT HOW FLORIDA WAS
GOING TO BE JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
WAIT TWO WEEKS, FLORIDA’S GOING
TO BE NEXT.
JUST LIKE ITALY, WE ARE EIGHT
WEEKS AWAY FROM THAT.
IT HASN’T HAPPENED.
WE SUCCEEDED AND I THINK THAT
PEOPLE JUST DON’T WANT TO
RECOGNIZE IT BECAUSE IT
CHALLENGES THEIR NARRATIVE, IT
CHALLENGES THEIR ASSUMPTION.
>> Sean: SO NOW GOING FORWARD
WE’VE LEARNED A VERY HARD
LESSON.
IF YOU PROTECT THE ELDERLY, WE
CAN SAVE THEIR LIVES.
IF YOU DON’T, THEN THEY WILL
DIE.
MORE PEOPLE WILL DIE.
LET’S DO THE RIGHT THING.
WE’VE LEARNED LESSONS.
WITH GOT TO PROTECT THOSE, BY
THE WAY, WITH HEALTH PROBLEMS.
WE ALSO NEED TO LEARN AS WE
REOPEN FROM THOSE WHO NEVER STOP
GOING TO WORK.
YOU KNOW, THEY’RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT REOPENING MEDICAL
MANUFACTURING CENTERS, FARMERS
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT REOPENING.
PACKERS ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
REOPENING, TRUCKERS ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT REOPENING.
THE GUYS THAT STUCK ALL THE
SHELVES IN NEW YORK ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT REOPENING.
THOSE THAT WORK IN DRUG STORES
IN NEW YORK AND LONG ISLAND,
THEY ARE NOT NOT TALKING ABOUT I
PEOPLE IN THE FOOD AND MEDICINE
COMPLIES -- THEY WORE MASKS AND
GLOVES AND OTHER MEDICAL PPE.
ALL THE PEOPLE I’VE SERVED AND
ALL THE STORES I GO TO, NOBODY
CONTRACTED COVID-19 AND THEY
KEPT THEIR STATES LIKE NEW YORK
I LIVE.
NEW YORKERS WOULD HAVE STARVED
TO DEATH.
NOBODY WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK IN
ANY HOSPITAL.
THEY KEPT THE SHELVES FULL, THE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT KEPT POURING
INTO NEW YORK EVERY SINGLE DAY,
SO WE LEARN FROM THAT SUCCESS.
WE ALSO LEARN FROM FAILURE.
IT’S NOW TIME TO REOPEN.
SADLY, PELOSI PROBABLY SEEMINGLY
WANTS TO DRAG THIS SHUTDOWN ON
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
REMEMBER HER MOTTO, NEVER LET A
GOOD CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
AS WE SPEAK SHE IS LITERALLY
REALLY VERY BUSY WITH TWO
IMPORTANT TASKS.
ONE, SHE’S WRITING ANOTHER
MASSIVE SOCIALIST SPENDING BILL
THAT WILL NEVER BECOME LAW.
NUMBER TWO, SHE’S OBSESSIVELY
RAGING ABOUT ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP, TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU’RE ASKING ME ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THE ACTIONS
OF THIS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, SO COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE IN SO MANY WAYS
THAT IT’S ALMOST A GIVEN.
IT’S LIKE A CHILD WHO COMES IN
WITH MUD ON THEIR PANTS OR
SOMETHING.
THAT’S THE WAY IT IS, THEY ARE
OUTSIDE PLAYING.
HE COMES IN WITH DOGGY DUE ON
HIS SHOES AND EVERYBODY WHO
WORKS WITH HIM AS THAT ON THEIR
SHOES TOO.
>> Sean: THE 80-YEAR-OLD
PELOSI ALMOST MAKES JOE BIDEN
SEEM COHERENT BY COMPARISON.
ALMOST.
WHAT IF WE START COMMENTING ON
HER LOOKS THE WAY SHE IS NOW
COMMENTING ON OTHER PEOPLES
LOOKS?
I WONDER HOW WELL THAT WILL GO
OVER IN THE MOB AND THE MEDIA.
AND BY THE WAY, WHERE DO WE
BEGIN?
PELOSI IS NOW USING THIS CRISIS
TO FUNNEL MONEY TO SOME OF HER
FAVORITES.
$1 TRILLION, A BLUE STATE
BAILOUT AS WE’VE BEEN
DISCUSSING.
BY THE WAY, YOU SAID IT,
REPUBLICANS, YOU HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, SECRETARY MNUCHIN,
LARRY KUDLOW, WHO WILL JOIN US
TONIGHT.
ALL OF YOU, DO NOT GIVE THEM ONE
SINGLE PENNY.
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE STATES ARE
NOT RESPONSIBLE TO BAILOUT
FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE STATES.
CALL YOUR SENATORS, FOR
EVERYBODY WATCHING TONIGHT AND
YOUR CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN, TELL
THEM NO WAY.
NO BAILOUT SOLICITS COVID-19,
AND THAT’S IT.
AND THEY DON’T WANT TO OPEN UP.
AT SOME POINT THEY’VE GOT TO PAY
FOR IT, NOT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
PELOSI ALSO WANTS PROTECTIONS
FOR THE MARIJUANA INDUSTRY.
SAY NO TO THAT.
SHE WANTS MONEY FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, SAY NO TO THAT.
SAY HELL NO.
SHE WANTS TO CHANGE VOTING LAWS.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS ALREADY
RECEIVED SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS.
A $45 MILLION POLITICAL ALARM TO
DEFEAT THE REPUBLICANS IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2020.
I DON’T THINK WE COME TO YOU,
THE PEOPLE, WE THE PEOPLE, THE
TAXPAYERS SHOULD BE BAILING OUT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHEN THEY’RE
SPENDING $45 MILLION ON
POLITICAL ADS, EVEN THOUGH THEY
SAY IT WILL BE RETURNING THE
$80 MILLION.
GOOD, FINALLY, BUT ARE YOU
CONNECTING THE DOTS HERE?
ESSENTIALLY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
SPENDING A FORTUNE TO ELECT
DEMOCRATS AND UNTIL THEY GOT
CAUGHT, THEY WANTED YOU, WE THE
PEOPLE TO PAY FOR IT ALL.
IN ONE OF THE DE FACTO LEADERS
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ, IS
NOW FACING A NEW WAVE OF
CRITICISM.
REMEMBER, SHE KILLED OFF ALL
THOSE AMAZON JOBS THAT WANTED TO
MOVE INTO HER DISTRICT,
HIGH-PAYING JOBS, CAREER JOBS
FOR PEOPLE.
WHILE, THE JOB LOSSES ARE NOW
PILING UP POST-COVID-19 IN
NEW YORK.
ALL WHILE AMAZON, THEY ARE
HIRING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
HERE WITH MORE, LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
SENATOR KENNEDY, THE PEOPLE OF
YOUR GREAT STATE, I’M STUCK
BECAUSE OF MY JOB RIGHT NOW AND
I’M GOING TO NEGOTIATE NEW YORK
OUT OF MY DEAL.
I DON’T WANT TO STAY HERE
ANYMORE.
I AM STUCK, BUT THE PEOPLE OF
YOUR GREAT STATE SHOULD NOT BE
BAILING OUT THE WASTE, FRAUD,
AND ABUSE OF NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, PENNSYLVANIA,
MICHIGAN, ILLINOIS AND
CALIFORNIA.
THEY SHOULDN’T SPEND A SINGLE
PENNY.
AND EVEN THOUGH THIS IS GOING TO
HURT ME, I AM TELLING YOU,
PLEASE TELL THE PEOPLE OF YOUR
STATE I SEND MY LOVE, MY GREAT
RESPECT AND DON’T SEND A PENNY.
THEY DON’T DESERVE IT.
>> WELL, I WILL -- I WILL SEND
THAT MESSAGE, SEAN.
I DON’T THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A FIFTH BILL.
I’M NOT AT ALL -- I’M NOT AT ALL
SANGUINE ABOUT THE PROSPECTS.
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES DISAGREE
WITH ME, BUT I THINK IT’S WAY
LESS THAN 50%.
THE REASON IS I THINK
SPEAKER PELOSI OVERPLAYED HER
HAND.
I MEAN, HER BILL IS SO
GRANDIOSE.
IT’S NOT A CORONAVIRUS BILL.
IT’S BASICALLY A REMAKE OF
WESTERN CIVILIZATION BILL.
AND I THINK THAT THE REPUBLICANS
IN THE SENATE WERE SO SHOCKED
WHEN THEY SAW IT THAT AT THIS
JUNCTURE, SHE COULD TAKE HER
BILL AND ELIMINATE EVERY OTHER
WORD AND CUT THE COST BY 75% AND
IT STILL WOULDN’T PASS.
AND IF SHE DOES THAT AND SHE
TAKES IT BACK TO THE
OCASIO-CORTEZ WING IN THE HOUSE,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO SUPPORT IT
IT.
SO I THINK SHE OVERPLAYED HER
HAND HERE.
>> Sean: OKAY -- EVERYBODY --
WE’VE LEARNED A LESSON.
EITHER WAY, THERE WAS A TIME
DURING THE MIDDLE OF THIS OR WE
WERE ALL AS A COUNTRY VERY
WORRIED ABOUT YOUR STATE OF
LOUISIANA BECAUSE OF MARDI GRAS.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS ANOTHER
DUMB DECISION BY ANOTHER DUMB
DEMOCRAT.
BUT WITH THAT SAID, YOU WERE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH IT.
THE PRESIDENT DID HIS JOB LIKE
HE DID IN NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
AND EVERY OTHER STATE, BUT YOU
WERE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
HOT SPOT A LOT BETTER AND A LOT
FASTER.
WHY?
>> ARE PRIVATE SECTOR.
WE HAD HELP FROM GOVERNMENT.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS
VERY RESPONSIVE AND VERY
GENEROUS IN TERMS OF PPE, IN
TERMS OF VENTILATORS.
THEY EVEN BUILT US A BRAND-NEW
HOSPITAL.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS I’VE
LEARNED FROM THIS POOL OF MISERY
THAT WE FOUND OURSELVES IN IS
THAT WE HAVE THE BEST PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM IN
THE WORLD.
IT PROVED THAT AND I KNOW SOME
OF MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS SAY WE
NEED GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
IF YOU SUPPORT GOVERNMENT-RUN
HEALTH CARE, I WANT YOU TO CLOSE
YOUR EYES AND IMAGINE LIVING IN
A WORLD DESIGNED BY THE
POST OFFICE.
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT WE WILL END
UP WITH.
THE PRIVATE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM PROVED ITS SUPERIORITY
THROUGH THIS CRISIS.
>> Sean: KEEP YOUR DOCTOR,
KEEP HER PLAN AND SAVE MONEY.
YOU ARE GIVING DENNIS MILLER A
RUN FOR HIS MONEY WHEN IT COMES
TO BEING VERY FUNNY, BUT YOU’RE
VERY FACTUAL.
>> I’M NOT IN MILLER’S CLASS.
HE’S WAY ABOVE MY PAY GRADE.
>> Sean: ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
OF THE PEOPLE OF YOUR STATE,
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU’RE DOING,
THANKS FOR GETTING THE MESSAGE
OUT.
TELL YOUR FELLOW REPUBLICANS
KNOW, THE ANSWER IS NO.
NO BLUE STATE BAILOUTS.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, RECORDS
SHOW THE BIDEN FOUNDATION --
LOOK HERE, THAT THEY PAID 120
GRAND TO THE EXACT SAME LAW
FIRM -- YOU KNOW, THE ONE THAT
THEY FUNNEL MONEY THROUGH FOR
HILLARY’S DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
THAT SHE PAID FOR TO INFLUENCE
THE 2016 ELECTION, BIDEN PAID
FOR IT IN 2018.
THE QUESTION IS WHY YOU MIGHT WE
WILL UPDATE YOU ON THAT STORY AS
IT CONTINUES TO UNFOLD.
ALSO TONIGHT WE HAVE NOTICED ONE
HOLIER-THAN-THOU SUPER PATRIOT,
JIM COMEY HAS BEEN AWFULLY QUIET
AS OF LATE.
NOW, BY THE WAY, HIS NAME
RECENTLY DISCLOSED IN THE NEWLY
UNREDACTED SUSAN RICE LETTER
ABOUT THE CYA.
THIS IS SUSAN RICE, WRITING
SUSAN RICE ABOUT A MEETING 15
DAYS AGO SAYING THREE TIMES IN A
ROW, BARACK OBAMA SAID BY THE
BOOK, BY THE BOOK.
DO IT BY THE BOOK.
MAYBE FINALLY TOOK MY ADVICE AND
MAYBE HE’S TAKEN THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT AND USING IT.
IT’S A LITTLE LATE, JIM, BECAUSE
YOUR CORRUPT LEADERSHIP AT THE
FBI IS UNDER FULL COMPLETE AND
RIFLE FIRE.
19 DAYS AFTER THAT MEETING IN
THE OVAL OFFICE WITH, LET’S SEE,
YOU AND CLAPPER AND BRENNAN AND
RICE AND GATES AND THE TEAM AND
OBAMA, ALL YOU DID 19 DAYS AFTER
WAS -- YOU DIDN’T DO ANYTHING BY
THE BOOK, YOU BURNED WHATEVER
THE BOOK IS.
YOU AMBUSHED AND SIGNED OFF ON
THE AMBUSH OF A 33 YEAR VETERAN
BY THE NAME OF GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN.
WHAT IS BY THE BOOK -- WHAT PART
OF BY THE BOOK WAS THAT ALL
ABOUT?
AS FOR THE ACTIONS OF SUSAN RICE
SUSAN RICE, FOR OBVIOUS CYA
LETTER ABOUT OBAMA’S INFAMOUS
JANUARY 5TH 2017 OVAL OFFICE
MEETING IS FRANKLY BIZARRE.
IT’S CLEAR THAT SHE WAS WELL
AWARE OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SURVEILLANCE OF
GENERAL FLYNN IN SO MANY OTHER
TRUMP ASSOCIATES.
DURING AN INTERVIEW ON
MARCH 22ND 2017 SHE LIED ABOUT
TOO AS SHE LIED ABOUT THE
BENGHAZI STORY AS WELL.
REMEMBER SHE WENT ON FIVE
SEPARATE MORNING SHOWS ENTRY
TOLD ONE LIE AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER KNOWING IT WAS A LIE.
REMEMBER, WHENEVER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION -- WHENEVER
THEY’RE OUT THERE AND THEY NEED